before you you know really got heavily
into acting what kind of job did you
have oh I was that dish network I was
under the houses and on top of roofs
wait you were actually putting the
dishes satellite guy was hanging off of
people's you know apartment buildings
and houses with the ladder and had the
dish on my back in the meter and a tool
belt and a drill all of that little
dangerous stuff man yeah I can imagine
that must be odd because that's a job
where you go into people's homes right
they call you up you don't know anything
you're just like yeah okay I'm from Dish
Network and then you show up and you
install did you what kind of stuff did
you see oh my god I see some some
terrible stuff you know some some people
who weren't so clean that wasn't funny
at all right right that's what the dish
people said when they came to my house
okay man come on the worst experience
was like he would like roaches
everywhere I was installing something to
hit it hit a curtain and literally I
promise you like roaches were just
falling like oh yeah their priorities
straight right will clean the house five
years from now but we got to get our
dish our satellite dish set up
you